le plaisir handball club faisait sa
rentrée avec un match de coupe de france
les plaisirs wa promu cette saison en
nationale iii recevait ce dimanche 3
septembre au gymnase nicholas lard le
club d'ici une équipe habituée à jouer
dans cette division
une équipe réellement profil des équipes
de nationale 3 à savoir des joueurs avec
un petit peu tous les profils et
notamment des grands gabarits qui sont
capables d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc ouais c'était très
intéressant de jeu cette équipe avec
voilà nos qualités sur le terrain la
différence d'expérience ne s'est pas
fait ressentir au coude à coude pendant
toute la rencontre le match s'est
terminé sur un score de parité 24
partout à la fin du temps réglementaire
des genres donc dû se départager par une
terrible séance de tirs au but quand
cette loterie c'est finalement ici qui
l'emportent 28 à 27 plaisir est éliminée
de cette coupe de france
le scénario du match a été fou les deux
équipes où leurs temps forts il est on
était devant ils sont remontés à la fin
quand je voulais dire à une minute de la
fin on est mené de deux buts et on se
retrouve à égalité donc c'est vraiment
un scénario fou qui donne pleins de
promesses pour la saison à venir pour
montrer qu' on essaie de tout faire pour
pour jouer jusqu'au bout et jusqu'à la
fin on est joueur parce qu'on continue à
être agressif et à aucun moment
on joue petit bras pour plaisir le
championnat de nationale 3 commencera
officiellement le 17 septembre prochain
avec la réception du club de massy